السلطات المواليه لروسيا قالت ان الجيش
الروسي تمكن من تدمير خط الدفاع الاول
للجيش الاوكراني في محور الزبرجيا والتوغل
لمسافه 7 كيلومترات في عمق الاراضي
الخاضعه لسيطره القوات الاوكرانيه
والسيطره على بلدات مهمه كما قالت تلك
السلطات ان القوات الروسيه بادرت بالهجوم
على طول خط الجبهه الذي يمتد من محيطي
مدينتي مدينه جوليا بول شرقيه زباروجيا
مرورا باريخ خوف وصولا الى كفوكا الجانب
الاوكراني نفر روايه الروسيه لجهه تقدم
قواتها وقال المتحدث باسم القوات
الاوكرانيه للجزيره ان قوتهم تسيطر على
كامله مواقعها كما اشار الجيش الاوكراني
الى استمرار القصف الروسي
هذا القصف اشار الاستمرار على اكثر من 20
منطقه في زفرجه اما عن محطه زبروجه
النوويه في مدينه اليروج غدار اتهمت شركه
الطاقه الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه بمواصله
اقامه التحصينات العسكريه في محيطي وحدات
الطاقه واصفه التحركات الروسيه بانها
تنتهي كو- جميع القواعد الحاليه للامان
النووي والاشعاعي
في باخمود قال الجيش الاوكراني انه تصدى
لمحاولات تقدم روسيه في محاور عده في
المدينه اضافه لتصده لهجوم في محور افديتك
جنوب دميه